Warren's unforced errors are amazing cuz
he you gotta really there's billionaires
watching this the way that you watch the
superball they watch this the way that
you watch the Superbowl and they go I
can't believe who is allowing this to
happen this [ __ ] took a DNA test to
prove that she was a Native American it
comes back she's not like no one forced
her to do it don't put a gun in her
mouth and force it do it these people
like the guys who own Raytheon in
General Dynamics and Boeing they're all
like what the [ __ ] is this [ __ ] doing
she's throwing the game and they can't
have that so you gotta back a guy like
mayor Pete a mayor Pete is a cool
cautious
you know cerebral guy hard to put him on
the fan but you know spent all his money
in Iowa they wanted a big showing in
Iowa but make no mistake none of this is
an accident
I don't believe that I don't believe any
of this is just happenstance I think
that part of the problem is that people
don't yet realize where we're at because
everything the economy is good and
people are largely employed even though
not a jobs that they want the ruling
class in this country is losing power
the people are turning against the
government really maybe for the first
time since the 1960s are you seeing
massive s'tel movements being built
where the aim is to upend the social
order people are taught Donald Trump was
a wrecking ball that people threw at the
system they didn't want Hillary they
didn't want Jeb
they don't want your Biden so if you're
a billionaire what do you what are you
to do you know you you have to find
somebody that these people are gonna
call it last behind you have to find an
Obama you have to find somebody who is
going to have you know the gravit
cos to keep the [ __ ] train running
cuz otherwise it gets messy Trump it's
messy
Sanders it'll be messy when you have an
anti-establishment guy in there that's
willing to call out the CIA call out the
FBI when you're willing to go to those
links to totally remake society starting
with your own political party Trump
remade the Republican Party Sanders will
have to remake the Democratic Party
Democrat big Democrat donors or our
[ __ ] losing their minds I know
somebody who works you know in a company
where like John Kerry's a partner and
you know John Kerry was was on the phone
the other day somebody overheard his
conversation he's like I mean why should
I run what are we gonna do like these
guys are losing their grasp on their
party they're losing their grasp on the
country and you're starting to see so
then they have to fight back they can't
just they're not gonna go quietly into
the night that's not what having
billions of you you don't amass billions
of dollars by being agreeable they're
not just gonna step aside they're gonna
have to kick up some dirt and they're
gonna do everything they can they've
thrown a lot of [ __ ] of Trump none of it
is stuck Trump is a corrupt guy he spent
years and years
hold on Chicago's a [ __ ] ambulance in
Chicago every somebody shot in Chicago
every 15 minutes so this is why there's
ambulances going on but they threw
everything at Trump nothing stock yeah
maybe when he's out of office something
will stock a stick I don't know I have
no doubt that there is corrupt dealings
that they could unearth by the way and I
have no doubt if they looked at Obama or
Clinton it's the same [ __ ] thing okay
but what are they gonna throw at Bernie
so the first thing they threw at Bernie
was just kerfuffle in Iowa where an app
couldn't tabulate all the votes and the
late reporting precincts all broke for
Bernie Sanders [ __ ] you you know what
this is you know what it is
Bernie could have come in Bernie won
Iowa he might have come out of there
not well you know with with a mandate it
might have started to look like the the
big money or the momentum he would never
of got he's not going to get the
money but the momentum clearly
grassroots party activists would all
kind of flow to him they've they've
bought themselves some time now now
Bernie's gonna - he's gonna win New
Hampshire then the meet he's gonna talk
about the New Hampshire doesn't really
matter this is the next thing they're
gonna do they gave it Wow we always knew
he was gonna win New Hampshire it
doesn't really matter we stole Iowa from
him and they're gonna hope that he gets
beaten in South Carolina
or on Super Tuesday and they're hoping
and praying to God and if by some
miracle he gets the nomination and wins
then they're going to do a version of
what they're doing to Trump he's not
gonna be allowed to govern with a
mandate he's going to be attacked from
all sides you know they're gonna have
people in the Democratic Party that are
turning on him in the same way that that
Republicans flipping on Trump this is
just what they're gonna do you might
hate Trump you might hate his politics
you might uh think he's a destructive
force in society all of that you you can
think is true you cannot doubt that from
the minute he took office there's been a
coordinated campaign from both the media
and the intelligence agencies to
discredit this presidency 100% and if
you think it's just Trump if you think
it's not gonna be Bernie you're out of
your mind they just don't want anybody
rocking the boat and they're gonna throw
scandals at Bernie they're gonna they're
gonna you know back people they're gonna
they're gonna turn people in his
administration against him they're gonna
have people spying I mean this is what
they've done forever it she's not gonna
change the the problem is it's becoming
more obvious they're getting more
desperate as you get more desperate when
you're a criminal and you get desperate
the crimes become on you start grabbing
things you know you know the old
smash-and-grab midday in the middle of a
public park you just [ __ ] grab
somebody's pocketbook and run why cuz
you're desperate that's not a highly
organized criminal activity you know
you're [ __ ] doing what you can
to steal some votes in Iowa from this
guy but it's very interesting to watch
happen the good news for all of us is
that corporations have governed the
country for a long time it's really not
the elections as important as they are
you know if Mark Zuckerberg stepped down
at Facebook it probably has more of an
effect on people's life then you're left
for now for now but it's gonna it's
gonna it's gonna ramp up and you're
gonna see just a constant fight until
the establishment can get a mayor Pete
in there until they can put an Obama
back in there until they can get
somebody who's [ __ ] just plays the
game it's just gonna keep getting worse
it's gonna keep getting obvious the
media which is now in 100% shill mode
and I mean to a point where they're
telling you your eyes and ears don't
work that's the job of the media now
they come until your eyes and ears don't
work what you just saw isn't happening
it's not happening what you just heard
isn't happening
that's the job of the media they go
there's nothing to this these conspiracy
before there were conspiracy theories
about Iowa good people on MSNBC be like
my car there's conspiracy - people think
that this shadow app is somehow
connected to I know that mayor peds
campaign funded it a lot of campaigns
funded it and listen I know a lot of the
people that design the app worked for
Hillary Clinton a lot of people work for
Hillary class stop it shut up eat your
Wendy's and go to bed Pig stop reading
articles
stop reading reddit threads and go to
bed everything's fine there's no
conspiracy here
what do you Trump what are you a Russian
I mean this is the full-time job of the
media right now